serious people are used to thinking
badly of celebrity culture they hate how
everyone wants to read about whether
latest big name has been on holiday or
who they're dating
they say it's silly and a sad reflection
of modern civilization such Stern
attitudes may sound sensible and Noble
but they are in truth deeply
irresponsible the impulse to admire and
have heroes is an important part of
human nature ignoring it or condemning
it won't kill it off it simply forces it
underground where it lurks undeveloped
prone to latch on to inappropriate
targets human beings need role models we
therefore shouldn't try to eradicate
celebrity culture we need to improve it
bringing a better kind of person to the
fore of public consciousness we need
better celebrities rather than no
celebrities Alexander Lukashenko is a
rather evil dictator of Belarus but this
doesn't mean that he doesn't care in a
way about making his country a better
place recently he's run a nationwide
competition to find a raft of new
celebrities Alena is very good at
milking cows on her best ever day she
pumped over a thousand 100 litres from
the herd into the tanks and recently her
prowess has been recognized by the
government of Belarus she has been named
officially the best milkmaid of
region which lies just south of the
capital Minsk it's like winning a major
talent competition on TV in the West
Eleanor travelled to the capital to pick
up an award from the President himself
she's been in all the papers Sasha too
has been honoured he held the 2015 title
of best welder of the Republic all
countries of course staged competitions
we regularly award prizes for excellence
at long-jump or throwing darts at a
board these things are recreational
though rather than focused on jobs or
the ordinary activities of everyday life
in Belarus the ambition is quite
different Eleanor and Sasha are national
celebrities the equivalent of hosts of
TV chat shows supermodels and tycoons in
other countries they are seen as
embodying ideals to which we should all
aspire meanwhile young couples are
encouraged to revere the example set by
two other prior
winners Natalia and Conan who've been
awarded the prize for Belarus's best
couple in love the Awards handed out in
Belarus are not ashamed to stress the
virtues of very ordinary people
the winners become famous but don't look
at all the way we've come to think that
famous people should most people in the
UK or Germany don't look sufficiently
smart or fashionable to be able to
become famous in those countries but
Belarus has focused entirely on how good
a person is at doing something basic and
useful like bringing up a family working
in a darriel helping make tractors these
are the country's only criteria of Fame
it's very unfortunate if we associate
these kinds of awards which bestows
celebrity status for excellence in
ordinary things with an Eastern European
dictator and his oppressive regime in
fact the good idea behind these awards
is universal it belongs as much in fact
more so in liberal States the core point
is that a lot of things we should care
about and need to take seriously are not
currently well treated by the media
machine that creates celebrity culture
but that's no reason to despair at the
idea of celebrity we should take more
seriously the task of creating good
celebrities good in the sense that one
would be honoring people who demonstrate
with particular clarity virtues that
need to be more prominent in society as
part of this new venture to create
better celebrities one might for example
set up prizes for the introvert who most
successfully managed to communicate what
he or she felt to their partner the
child who most generously forgave their
parents the worker who most
intelligently defused infighting at the
office and perhaps the biggest prize of
all the husband who best learned to
control his temper and say sorry we
don't need to stop having celebrities we
just need to put some slightly more
helpful ones in front of our eyes
you